كل الانظار تتجه الان نحو الهند حيث امر
باقامه الصلوات في المعابد ورفع اكف
الدراعه في المساجد الى السماء ان يكلل
الهبوط على سطح القمر بنجاح
نشرت وكاله الفضاء الهنديه صورا التقطتها
مركبتها الفضائيه
للقطب الجنوبي للقمر وقالت الوكاله ان
المركبه في طريقها للهبوط مساء يوم
الاربعاء بعد ايام فقط من فشل مركبه
الهبوط الروسيه في تلك المهمه
نحن على وشك الهبوط في الثالث والعشرين من
اغسطس انها مناسبه بالغه الاهميه بالنسبه
الى الهند وعلامه فارقه فيما يتعلق
باستكشاف الفضاء
وكاله الفضاء الهنديه اكدت ان جميع
الانظمه على المركبه الفضائيه التي انطلقت
في الرابعه عشر من يوليو تموز تعمل بشكل
مثالي ولا يتوقع حدوثه اي طارئ في يوم
الهبوط
[تصفيق]
وبعد الفاشل في عام 2019
ينظر الى محاوله الهند الثانيه للهبوط على
سطح القمر على انها تعبير عن اصرار
مؤسساتها العلميه
ومثابرتها وسيكون لنجاح المهمه اثار في
مكانه البلاد قوه فضائيه واكتشاف القمر في
المستقبل
تحاول العديد من القوه العالميه الوصول
الى القمر لغرض الاستكشاف والوجاهه لكن
ثمه دوافع اخرى وراء السباق الجديد الى
القمر فقد اجرت القوه الكبرى كالولايات
المتحده والصين والاتحاد الاوروبي محاولات
عده لصبر اغوار القمر خلال السنوات
الماضيه وكان هناك تركيز على القطب
الجنوبي حيث لم تتمكن اي دوله من الوصول
اليه بعد التضاريس الوعره هناك تجعل
الهبوط صعبه كما انه اكثر جفافا بمئه مره
من الصحراء الكبرى لكن المكافاه قد تكون
كبيره
وتاريخيه اكتشاف اثار لمياه متجمده في
الحفر على سطح القمر يعني استخدامها
لاستخراج الوقود والاكسجين ومياه الشرب
واقامه مستعمرات في المنطقه الطويله الامد
لاستخراج الموارد
وكان من المقرر ان تهبط المركبه الروسيه
لون خمسه وعشرون على القطب الجنوبي هذا
الاسبوع لكن لم يعد مسيطرا عليها حين
اقتربت من سطح القمر فتحطمت لقد كانت اول
مهمه روسيه الى القمر منذ نحو 50 عاما
تهدف الى رفع مكانه روسيا في الداخل وفي
الفضاء لكن فشلها كشف عن تحديات ربما
تتجاوز برنامج الفضاء الروسي